同学们好，咱们开始上课，很开心啊，又上新课了。
这个关于短剧啊，相信很多同学最近频繁听到关于他的新闻对吧？包括什么投入40万收入破亿呀，对吧？一部短剧，一夜之间实现财富自由啊，对吧？这些新闻都很吸引人。所以很多同学啊呃想让我给大家讲一讲啊。
我是怎么发现这个短剧最近非常火？
是在咱们的编剧库里。
同学们都知道啊，我在网上讲了呃4年的编剧课，我们有很多的学生，我们也有自己的编剧库啊，咱们自己培养的学生呢呃咱们自己签下来，然后来给甲方和平台方提供剧本啊。
然后从今年年初开始就有大量的短剧订单啊，开始我还不知道是个啥啊吧，然后就慢慢关注这个领域。甚至有一个甲方来跟我说，一下要100部短剧的剧本啊，我才开始重视这个问题。后来确实发现这个市场在快速的发展啊。因为咱们的编辑库里面的学生很多都是小白啊。
零基础入行的，通过学我的课程入行的这种同学很多。所以说短剧既然对小白很友好，那么咱们呢也抓住现在这个机遇啊，这个上升期嗯给大家。
讲一下短剧的创作方法。
首先呢先给大家啊确立几个观点。
他们说的啊投入40万，收入过亿，有没有这个事情啊？
有。
而且不是一亿。
截止到目前为止啊，有一部短剧已经2亿了，确实是投入40万，收入2亿啊，叫无双这部短剧。
但是。
它不是你想象的那么简单的。
还有它严密的产品生产的一个过程，以及投放营销的一个流程啊，不是你想的那么简单的。咱们在课程中呢会给大家详细介绍。第二，很多同学觉得哎呀，那这个东西现在是是不是就对小白非常友好，我是小白，我就可以写短句呢？跟大家强调一下，短剧，现在启用的编剧。
确实有大量的小白。
但是是为什么呢？是因为这个产品啊还没有磨出型。
没有形成规律，导致甲方和制作方找不到合适的编距。所以在大量的试大量的启用小白。
并不是说你是小白，就适合干这个事儿，你也是需要学习的。
好吧。
第三呢还有很多同学啊觉得老师。
我写过网剧，写过电视剧是吧？我来搞这个东西，是不是就是降维打击啊？
千万别这么想。
短句和你前写过的。
网剧也好，网文也好，不是同一个东西。
它是一个新的产品形式，它有它新的规律，你还是要学习的。你如果大大咧咧走过去，认为自己可以叫一打鸡，那你有可能。
是要吃亏的，好吧。
所以咱们这节课就给大家系统的讲一下短句是怎么回事，以及它怎么创作的。
听过咱们课的同学都知道啊，我讲课有原则，先告诉大家它是个什么东西。
它的原理是什么？再告诉大家，他为什么会这样运作。
知其然知其所以然以后，我们再研究创作方法，这样的话更有针对性。你也可以更容易理解我们为什么要这么写。否则如果我们前面对产品认知对不齐的话，你后面怎么写就搞不清楚了。第一类我们统称为横屏短句，横屏短句啊，就是指。
甚是芒果TV啊，他们搞的那些短剧。但是在咱们的课程里面，咱们不认为它是短剧。因为它通常啊是10分钟左右，它就是传统的长距平台横屏的长距平台。对于这块市场的一次试探，现在还不成熟，所以我们暂且不去理解它，或者是说我们把它按照长距理解。
那么第二大类呢就是竖频。那竖屏短句呢也分两大类啊。第一类呢就是抖快平台在抖快平台上直接播放的竖频短句，我们也经常看到啊，经常刷到。第二大类呢，我们称之为小程序短剧，是你在抖快上看到这个短剧的一些介绍。
片花。
广告是吧？我们统称为线索。然后你产生兴趣之后，他把你导到一个小程序上，然后去那里完成剩余的观看，甚至是付费或者是观看广告的一系列行为。好吧，这种是小程序短句。然后这两种剧呢都是竖屏的，一般来说呢都是。
一两分钟一级。
当然了，平台的视频短句啊有时候会产生一些形式上的变化。为什么呢？是因为平台上的短句啊又分两种，一种呢我们叫免费拍出来之后啊啊，你随便看免费的它是怎么一个运作方式呢？一般来说啊，这个账号啊本身有一定的粉丝量。
或者是呢这个参演的这个个演员啊，他本身是个网。
所以说免费的这种短剧呢，它的盈利模式是什么？一般是接广告。
啊，接点广告，因为它免费嘛。当然了，平台为了鼓励这种创作啊，会给一些这个分账。我们可以理解它还是一个t B的一个一个模型啊。
星忙计划呀，新番计划这种好吧，那平台上有没有付费的呢？也有啊也有我们叫端上付费，端上付费啊，就在平台你相中这个剧了，直接可以付点钱，看后面的全集端上付费。这个呢目前也在。
测时间。
他的盈利模式当然端上付的这个费是一部分。另外一部分呢依然是广告。
当然了，这两部分由于都有网红的参与啊，还有网红的一个二股。
因为它毕竟形成一个一个有流量的1个QOL嘛，它可以进行一些别的转化是吧？带个货什么的，或者是结合广告什么。
所以说平台上的视屏短句呢有免费的，也有端上付费的。你可以理解是请自付。我们用网上充值的术语啊，那么小程序啊看到一个素材感兴趣了，去到一个小程序上。
他说看完后面要付多少多少钱，或者是解锁下面实几要付多少多少钱，这实际是中付费中付费的一个逻辑吧。你们听说的那些。
40万收入2亿或者是一夜之间财富自由。
指的是这种小程序的署名短，竖名短句基本上分这么三种，目前正在爆发的是第三种。那么前两种呢免费的有没有爆掉的，有爆掉的，有很多像石七呀、什么大英博物馆呀都爆掉的。
但是呢它的盈利模式目前尚不成熟，为什么呢？依赖平台它就它有一个转移支付的问题啊，目前正在爆发的是第三种，我们要做这个东西啊，必须了解这个市场啊。当然这个市场迅速的在变化，新的东西出来了，它发展是很快的。同学们我们要注意两点啊，新的东西出来了。第一。
第一时间进去。
抢滩登录不要管为什么。
甚至不用完全学好就可以扎进去。
先是。
瞧。
扎个坑再说。
第二，你要知道它是有变化。
我们的课程当然是总结到目前为止的规律，老师也会不断的迭代。
就是注意两点啊，新的东西现在就是这个状态，市场现在就是这样一个情况啊，你要了解它知其然啊知其然。那目前在做小程序短剧运营的人都有哪些呢？
主要分三部分人，第一部分人是小说，第二部分人呢是游戏，第三部分人是影视。现在有三部分人在做这件事情，或者是说在瞄准这件事情发力，但这两部分人都没有做小说的人多，而且是做的最成功的。
目前我看到的几乎所有的以前做小说充值的平台。
转做小程序短剧的这种公司没有一个赔钱的，而且都在高歌猛进。
目前来说啊，所有的之前是做小说平台的，现在转做短句的。
都在赚钱，而且都在高歌猛进。为什么呢？因为小说的人既懂运营也懂内容，还有两个优势。为什么小说平台都做的很好？第一个优势他有IP优势，他有小说库呀，他知道哪些故事观众爱看验证过呀，还有第四个优势。
具写错了啊，大的小说平台。
他的累积充值用户啊都过千万，啥意思啊？他手里有过千万个手机号，这是优质的数据啊，他有充值习惯呀。所以说他们在投放的时候啊，可以拿自己的数据去跟短视频平台的数据库做一个对重。对他们的投放成本会低啊，准很多同学说老师啊，这个重负费我真的是不理解啊。
谁会干这事儿？
中国的市场非常。
而且中国的市场分层非常的明确啊，这是一个市场现状，每年给小说充值是100。
约女朋友看电影，你觉得这是个大市场，一年就几百亿。
我们说短句啊有个很重要的作用。也就是说他为什么会重付费，实际是解压，有些人会比较直白的说叫YY，实际是解压。因为这部分人啊他压力比较大，所以他需要这个心理。
治愈心理按摩啊，这才是短剧最重要的作用。
那么最早的画像啊，当时大家认为就是。
这一部分男性的幻想。
准婿离婚龙王打。
这种套路的剧也是最多的。最早。但是后来大家发现哎女频也很多嘛，虐练也很多嘛，也很多人付费啊，都市修仙金手指穿越重生对吧？全都有市场。所以说。
从我们的观点认为。
不要轻易去给一个大市场的用户进行画像。他既然是个未来是一个千亿，甚至是数千亿级别的一个市场。那他们的用户在未来的发展中一定会涵盖几乎所有画像的。
但是这些人物有个共同的需求，是这样。
这个是我们要。
不同的人群他需要什么样的解压方式？你看这8年来女频的充值已经跟男平差不多了。
那女频呢基本上都是与爱情相关的呀。那女孩子嘛对吧？还有爱情方面的需求。
是很正常。所以说不要去定义用户，定义用户的需求。我们说传统的长剧，电影也好，电视剧也好，网剧也好，它的顺序就是故事第一。
展美第二。
压力在。
但是。
小程序短句，我们的第一需求是这样，然后是审美，最终是故事。因为现在我听到很多人说啊，说老师啊这个小程序短句啊拍的太low了，故事讲不明白，我要拍一个把故事讲。
同学啊。
他能不能上哎U腾啊？我没有说故事不重要，但是他没有解压重要，甚至也没有审美重要。你想想看。
一个小程序短剧给我带来一个心灵玛杀机，随着他的剧情YY，对吧？这是我的第一需求。我在满足了这个需求之后，我如果还有闲心，那我就要挑一挑你的演员掌。
服装漂不漂亮，演员漂不漂亮，最终的需求才是啊你这个故事实际上也还行是吧？各种反转呀，各种设计啊，也还符合我的一个标准，一定要搞清楚。这就是我为什么说很多传统饮食的人，你可要注意了。
你来有可能把故事把劲儿全使在故事上。
我再次强。
同学们，我在网上教大家讲故事，教了好。
我在这个行业是学生最多的老师，我们也是编剧科第一IP，我们也是全国最大的编剧库。
编剧联盟。
你以为我不想讲故事吗？
你以为我会认为故事不重要吗？
说出这句话，我的心比你痛。同学们，所以你一定要跟着老师纠正这个观念。
故事不是不好，但是在这个产品里面，它不是最重要的。小程序短具最重要的实际上是用户充值它有个转化，就充值充值显然要给人解压，甚至。
甚至还要有点上头，那么就引发我们的课程。
关于解压。
我们会给大家讲在后面的课程当中啊，我们这节课是让大家认知一下短句。从下节课课开始，我们就要教大家创作短句了。
那么从下节课开始，我们会从这三个方面给大家分别。
不同的知识，关于解压，我们会给大家讲如何创造双点。
人类共同的爽点有哪些？
每一种爽点的。
变成情节的方式，也是哪些情节是支撑这种床点。
这是我们课程的内容之一。
然后关于代入呢，我们会教大家塑造人。
因为这个人物要与我们的观众是命运共同体呀，我们要共情他，要有共同的感情呀。
对不对？我们会和教大家塑造人物啊，塑造人物以及关于这个人物他的故事，他的成长线，他的故事发展。然后年度呢我们会教大家瞎钩子。
如何下钩子，如何做悬念，如何吸引观众一步一步的看下去，这些都是咱们后面课程会给大家讲的一些内容。总而言之啊，关于新竖屏小程序短句这个新兴的产品啊。
个人是非常看好。
为什么呢？
有这么几点原因，第一，它是一个新的互联网。
他更具备互联网思维呀。
我们说这几年啊，咱们的观众啊已经被短视频这个东西啊。
教育。
我们现在花很多时间在刷短视频啊，这种短促而直接的刺激我们很喜欢呀。同学们有没有发现一个问题啊？自从你爱刷爱上刷短视频以后啊，你现在看书都没有什么耐性了。看剧，你有时候都背速快进拖拽是吧？十分钟速看电影，5分钟速看电影，因为。
观众被教育的。
更希望得到更集中的信息了。
短句显然是更符合这种，它是新的一个。
它更符合目前互联网的思维。
第一个优势第二个优势还是说这个变现，它的变现路径短且直接，从观众直接给到片方，在互联网上啊付费短是合理的。
没有中间商赚差价的。所以说基于这两点判断，我认为啊未来当然会有发展变化。但是这个产品我们是看好。
所以说才会有咱们这套课程。咱们的同学当中啊有小白，想通过这个新的一个业态进入这个。
创作领域去实现创作变现很好。
有呢写小说的我本来是写小说的那现在大家都在搞这个我也来搞挺好，那你要来学一学。第三种人呢，以前想搞影视或者正在搞影视的对吧？那你也要虚心一点，不要觉得你是来教鸭子的，好吧。
不管是哪种同学，咱们后面会对到大家具体的创作方法，希望大家都能学到啊，希望大家都能在这个新的领域赚到钱，吃到红利。好吧，同学们好，短剧市场全面爆发，动辄用户充值破千万。现在真的是新人创作者入行的绝佳机遇。查理老师精心制作的短剧课重磅上线，一整套系统完整的短剧创作课程。
从认知创作到实际制作，干火满满，内容权威，打造一站式学习模式，对小白尤其友好，不需要专业背景，没有学历限制，都可以跟随查理老师学习，然后进入查理老师的短剧联盟，结单赚钱，查理老师众多短剧头部公司达成了长期战略合作关系，每月有超百部的短剧订单。专攻查理老师的学员投稿。
助力同学快速拿到结果。而且这一次参加短句课的同学还能进入由查理老师亲自带班的专属学习群，看同学一起交流分享。是的，你没听错，查理老师亲自带班，现在报名查理老师的短剧课，还有早鸟假，名额有限，报名方式补贴在视频里了，快截图添加吧。